welcome to this video playing mere mere
polymer Paula what the heck a pretty new
account not many games played strange
combination just bullet and five minutes
okay yeah well South Africa does not
have many many IM so and you never know
people can can choose their flex em
freely okay very quick b5 here i'm not
sure that this is such a reliable
variation but it's it's possible of
course yeah white is trying its best to
make it difficult for black to play c5
it's not so easy to do but still what
wider tries to achieve I think black
okay
maybe this is useful for the fight for
the c5 square not losing any time now c5
there's always this issue of the b5
point hanging okay so there are some
chances now to to keep c5 prevented
further for the time being maybe you can
play it anyway with some sort of porn
sec okay
yeah what's your point now if you know
the hideous no point so we just wants to
suffer in this pollution it seems yes
women should have been avoided by black
yes the only counterplay has us with the
fire of course so I'm putting something
on the D file I wait empty i can just
take here i can just take this alack
resign sorry it already was a bit tricky
in this position I mean what is this for
what pieces this young b7 and this was
very strange for for someone so hydrated
because you absolutely must get NC 5 he
simply didn't do anything about that it
starts here in fact this isn't it this
is an idea I'm not saying that it is a
perfect move but it is an ID yet ctrl z
5 and it keeps g7 on the right square
the night here to control C 5 okay this
it didn't do and I mean you really need
to play 97 or I don't know we need you
need to do something even this this type
of move as an idea to get in something
like this maybe take here it's probably
not not correct but it's you absolutely
cannot allow that I mean he went for
this bad position really quickly like
it's the the most normal thing in the
world to defend it but it really isn't
isn't good yeah what what should he do
here he cannot play e5 cannot play 97
yeah I really don't know computer wants
to play 95 then probably not be too is
going to be played you can take but what
does this help really it's still this
tall porn on b7 this is also move not
bad with e 5 still possible later the
auntie Ramona's just the bishop yeah
strange game he somehow it didn't really
address the issue of the c5 square and
this is then a very nice position for
wide okay thanks for watching